it all comes down to this the biggest
game of the regular season on the final
day today is the most important game of
the season because you control your own
destiny it's all about the giants you
win today you are national league west
champs logan webb is a guy who's been
one of the best pitchers in the game
since may today is going to be a huge
start for him the last time he saw the
padres they roughed him up a little bit
in the first inning he bounced back
nicely but this will be a good test and
see how he's managing those emotions
trent grisham stands in here's the
one-two pitch swing and a missy struck
it out
with the sinking fastball that ended up
down below the knees here's tatis junior
3-2 pitch swing and a miss he struck him
out and he got him to face that
two-seamer
and he must have so much movement on
that pitch he's got each of the first
two padres hitters to swing out of the
strike zone two down here is machado one
two pitch
struck him out swinging
a great slider that started in the
strike zone and then broke sharply down
and out of the strike zone and off the
outside corner
and in this big game
webb starts it out by
striking out the side on three swinging
strike three webb struck out the side in
the first it'll be cronenworth myers and
frazier
line drive
caught by longoria paul gets by longoria
has a chance for two two bases to leave
the inning off but longoria says now i
got this one spears it right the sweet
spot so here's frazier
line drive
and the atom ball here in the second
inning number three nothing nothing
score logan webb back in the mountain
and a swing and a missed strike three
got him with the slider out number one
here in the third it's gonna be reese
kneer the pitcher's gonna hit him
strikeout number five
webb goes nine up nine down it'll be the
eight nine one batters for the giants
ace reece kinnear evan longoria evan
longoria after the first pitch to deep
center field trent grisham has just
enough room and he makes the catch
one pitch one out in the bottom of the
third i got it i got it i got it as the
bullpen watches
out number one here in the third logan
webb against kinnear
webb hits one into left center field
grisham broke the other way and webb's
got a hit grisham did not get a great
read and jump the first hit of the game
comes
from the pitcher logan webb a one out
single here in the bottom of the third
webb at second two down wilmer flores
space hit
here comes webb
grisham's got a good arm the throw and
webb will be held up and in the second
goes flores giants have loaded the bases
with two down here in the bottom of the
third or buster posey
face hit left field here comes webb
right behind the flores the throw home
cut off
giants take the lead
there's that change up and hangs right
up there at the belt and posey says
that's where i like it
and with a two out jump an easy score
for webb and flores i think there's any
emotion from the the old timer buster
posing you bet laura's at third posey at
first two down crawford line drive
center field and chasing it down as
grissom
the giants cannot avoid gresham trent
grisham was gonna lead off here in the
top of the fourth
lines that one the other way and it's a
fair ball grisham on his way around
first base going for two bryant will not
have a play and a lead-off double here
in the fourth inning padres have their
first base runner against logan webb so
now runner at third one out for machado
he's been great in these situations this
year and he hits this one in the air out
to center field that'll get it done the
estrenski there grisham tagging and the
padres on the board in the fourth inning
it's giants two grisham one and lumet
has loaded the bases with three walks
with only one out and a guy who doesn't
often chase out of the strike zone is
coming up
right field it's going to fall
they will hold
la stella comes through it's three to
one
great to strike a bat from tommy la
stella and that's going to be it for
lumet greg stamen the new pitcher base
is still loaded with one out wilmer
flores who has hit the ball hard twice
today
down the left field line nobody's there
and the giants are off and rolling
lestramski scores lestella will be held
up at third webb scores
flores comes through
and the giants add on it's five to one
and he does it in a two-strike count
stamen comes back with another curveball
and it flat out hangs it and flores make
some pay that
at-bat for giants fans was therapeutic
hit them where they ain't then that's
what flores did and here's wade
wade goes the other way
mariznick back and he will reach up and
make the catch
everyone tags it's six to one
it's six to one two down runner at third
for posey who had the big hit in the
third and has been on base both times
long drive base head he's done it again
it's 7-1 7-1 giants and buster posey not
messing around in the final game of the
year posey two for two on base three
times he's knocked in three runs already
here's myers fifth inning
got him six strikeout first called
strike three two on two out now tommy
pham the veteran swing
and a foul tip held by buster posey on a
change-up for the strikeout he's got
five shutout innings in the book
and seven strikeouts already bryant in
scoring position with logan webb coming
up and
logan webb not only is he pitched well
he scored twice in this game
get down the left field line
and uh
take the tour ken you deserve it
on the last day of the season
the giants pitchers have hit a home run
logan webb has hit his first home run a
two-run boat of lightning
and the giants have a nine to one lead
first big league homer in the biggest
game of the year one down here's
fernando tatis junior
got him batiste knew it eight strikeouts
machado with a sacrifice fly in the
fourth big grounded on the first base
side diving is floored as he's got it up
to his knees picks the ball up jumps up
close the web covering in time for the
out outstanding defensive play there
giants have two on with nobody out and
mike
coming up he drives one left center
field hit very well
it is off the bottom of the wall two
runs are going to score and the giants
make it 11-1
and the celebration is on here
[Applause]
blasting one to left center field his
first hit of the day to a single for
marisnick his first of the game only the
fourth hit of the game allowed by logan
webb
now i swing there's a soft liner out
into shallow left center that's going to
get down for a hit coming around second
digging for third marisdick the throw in
is too late i've been two hits in a row
here to start the inning reevos with his
first hit of the game
hit hard and through the right side a
base hit pinch it rbi single for
carratini as mariznick checks in
reevos goes first to third and three
straight hits here in the eighth inning
and here comes gabe kepler and
this place is about to go nuts and he
will never forget this cheer by the way
ever
and webb heads to the dugout to a
lusty ovation for the big crowd
i have runners at the corners with
nobody out and there's the new pitcher
kevin castro the new pitcher now for
gabe kepler
grissom rips it to right field and wade
can't get there
rivas will come in to score and four
consecutive hits for the padres here in
the eighth the bases are loaded so
here's cronenworth faces are loaded and
all of a sudden there's a little
low buzz in the stadium
line drive left field coming in as brian
he makes the diving catch it'll be a
sacrifice fly but the giants get the out
it's 11-4 here a bullet and nice play
from bryant coming in spearing this now
the giant three outs away from winning
the national league western division
title in 2021
on the ground to crawford
crawford will wait for a better hop got
him one down in the ninth here's rivas
got him two down in the ninth
so here's hosmer 36 000 on their feet
it's two balls and two strikes got him
the giants
for the first time since 2012
are champions of the national league
west
and let this celebration begin and let
it go on for a while
and the san francisco giants have done
what was said they could not do they
have beaten l.a for the national league
western division title